a couple of tough finishes to playoff
runs for the saints the last two years
the minneapolis miracle and then the
debacle in the superdome with the
non-call that kept the saints from
getting back to the super bowl and chris
sims as we continue on this thursday
edition of pft live we're taking a look
at the saints off season and drew brees
still there that's not a surprise they
restructured his contract to kick the
can on some of that 30 plus million in
cap space he was going to have mark
ingram's out latavius murray is in not a
lot of other movement i think the most
significant signing the arrival of tight
end jared cook a guy the raiders very
much wanted to keep a guy who has shown
flashes of brilliance in the past and a
guy that i think drew brees is going to
need uh to complement what they can do
on the outside of the receiver position
yeah
no no doubt about it i mean jared cook i
mean they haven't had a legit titan uh
tight end like this since jimmy graham
left you know a guy that they're gonna
go okay we can go into every game with
about 15 or 20 plays that's just called
you know the jared cook section of the
play sheet to where sean payne's going
to look at it and go okay how am i going
to get this big guy the ball how do i
want to move him around so that's
very exciting for the new orleans saints
and i think a perfect combination for a
guy like drew brees who i said in that
mashup i don't know if he necessarily
can beat you with his big arm and making
power type throws like he used to tight
ends usually are over the middle right
in front of you that is better for that
type of quarterback saints you kind of
said it not a huge like off season uh i
thought it was a smart free agency
getting latavius murray adding a few bit
max unger
retires you replace him and get nick
easton from the minnesota vikings i
thought that was a big time move got
more big people on their defense and
offensive line again though that's the
one thing mike that i just look at on
the saints when i first look at the
roster it really jumps out to me the
amount of good defensive linemen and the
amount of good offensive linemen they
have they're about top five in both
areas in football and that is always
going to give them a chance against no
matter who they play you know they
didn't have a first round pick this year
because they used it to trade up last
year to get marcus davenport a pass
rusher who was disappointing last year
because of injury they have high hopes
for him this season and then this year
they gave up a second round pick in 2020
to trade up with the dolphins to get
center eric mccoy out of texas a m to
help fill that void that was created
when max unger suddenly retired so some
needs
forcing mortgaging a little bit of the
future this year last year it was more
of a luxury thing but you know i i'm
sure they would have loved to have had
that first round pick this year i mean
that's a big thing to give up just to
move up in round one and uh especially
when the guy ends up being so far a
disappointment but they they really need
him to justify the move that they made
last year to get him uh because it's
going to become glaring that they've
blown an opportunity to add a quality
young player this year all in the name
of getting davenport unless davenport
ends up playing like a quality young
player yeah that's you're right that's a
huge question i mean they gave up assets
to go up and get a guy because they
thought hey we're in the super bowl
window and we have a desperate need on
the other side of our defense across
from cameron jordan who is one of the
best defense ends in football that
nobody talks about but they wanted
another guy there and davenport mike
i'll say this i haven't lost confidence
in him he he had an injury-filled year
to where i don't think we ever really
got to see the full capabilities of the
player it's hard as a rookie you're
swimming mentally physically then you
get injured and you're thrown out of
whack and you're never 100
i would expect him to have a big year he
was a guy i liked in the draft and i
liked him even from what i saw before he
got hurt last year but it wasn't much
playing time before that i i still think
the saints i look at them with sean
payton this football team i do think
they take a fall a little bit right mike
but
i still think they're going to go to the
playoffs like if you made me pick
there's no way i can't sit here and take
sean payton drew brees and some of these
big studs they got up front on both
sides of the ball and not pick them to
get in the nfc playoffs i think the the
reality is and this is a theme that
we've been discussing that something
happened with drew brees last year
during the season they better hope it
was an injury because injuries heal if
it was a decline due to the fact that
he's now 40
and and
week 6 week 10 you know became most
noticeable the night they ran into the
dallas cowboys buzz saw
after they had been racking up points
but um yeah
maybe week six is when the evidence of
it first started to show up and you know
with franchise quarterbacks the
challenge is for the coach to come up
with easy touchdowns easy wide open
plays draw up plays that make the
quarterback look good and then the
quarterback sometimes will make throws
and make the coach look good i just
don't know how much of that breeze can
do now and it's it you know as you've
said in the past it may be that sean
payton's gonna have to draw up some
brilliant plays far more often than not
to put brees in a position where he can
make the throws because he may not be
able to make the tough throws anymore
yeah i think that's a very fair question
and you know to the point of what you're
saying i know yes we both have talked
about this a lot even at the end of last
year you know hey let's think about at
the end of last year and even the
playoffs when the saints needed a big
explosive throw they usually let taysom
hill throw it a few times at the end of
the year i thought that was a little bit
of a telltale sign right there that oh
you know the guy drew brees he just
can't push it down the field the way a
younger guy can let's figure out
something there with him the controversy
will play in the nfc championship game
the guy's wide open if bree spots him
and zips it nickel robin doesn't even
get there in time to blow up the play
it's a touchdown more pft live coming at
you right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports